so when the web first began there was no
way to do layout
it's like the first image on the left
you just had a block of content because
the web was never meant for doing all
kinds of creative designing things that
we see on the web today no the web was a
way for people to share information and
that is still true today it's just that
the presentation has improved
significantly so this this is just a
summary of how web des Arts has evolved
over the years now because the wet was
never meant to do a lot of the things
that we use it for today a lot of the
methods that people used to design web
layouts in the past were hacks so people
use things like HTML tables which by
rights were meant for designing tables
but people realize that you know we can
hack these HTML tables to create all
sorts of more creative ways of
presenting content on the web and then
people started to use CSS and use floats
to make layouts but again floats we're
not meant for doing layout and that's
why it is so hard for people to get the
layouts that they want using floats and
eventually it got so painful that we
just see that all this pain to
frameworks so everybody's website looks
like it was built on bootstrap or some
other variant of bootstrap so CSS
frameworks actually shielded us from a
lot of the pain but also made websites
look very similar so what I'm talking
about today is a new CSS property you
call CSS grid that can potentially
change all of that
so alongside flexbox which is also a
relatively recent addition to CSS we now
have a means of doing layout on the web
that we've never had before and some
people have asked a question like we
already have flexbox why do we need grid
oh it's been meant to replace flexbox
wrong question the fact is that grid and
flexbox are meant to be complementary
they're meant to be used together so
that we can build layouts that are truly
native to the web the correct mindset we
should be having is grid and flexbox
because Britain flexbox are best friends
they are like kaya and butter they are
like nuts and bolts they are like jay-z
and Beyonce they are good on their own
but together they can achieve another
level of Awesome so when we use flexbox
and if you are not a web developer
please continue to enjoy the free drinks
and the bar but if you are web developer
and you have to use flexbox remember
that flexbox
operates on a single dimension so there
is no relationship between the rows and
the columns of elements that you layout
using flexbox it is like a really long
daisy chain of flex elements when it
comes to CSS grid things are a little
bit different because CSS grid operates
on two dimensions and because of this
CSS grid and flex box can work together
really well first to achieve the layouts
that we want to build so here's just
some basic terminology that I will be
referring to throughout the talk
basically what you have are grid lines
that we use to specify exactly where we
want our content to go the spaces
between these grid lines are known as
retracts
so they can be great rows or they can be
great columns depending on your
direction by default a single grid item
will take up one grid cell and a great
area is merely a collection of grid
cells but the most useful feature of bit
I feel is the ability to define brick
gaps because again if you've tried to
design a layout with gutters between
your your grid elements you would have
realized that
it's a very tedious endeavor and if
you've never done that before trust me
when I say that it could potentially be
a very tedious endeavor
so both flexbox and bid operate on a
container child relationship whereby you
apply the display property onto the
parent and this makes all the children
of that parent Brit or flex items
so Rachel Andrew who worked on the
specification for great sums it up very
nicely by saying that Brit works from
the container in whereas all the other
layout methods that we've used before
start with the item so we can illustrate
this with some examples so say I have
six items as you can see and I want to
lay them up in a you know a very boring
three column grid what I would do is
that I would have to define a width on
each of the elements so in this case I'm
using inline block and I have to make
sure that each of my items are 1/3 of
the container it's almost exactly the
same if you use float you also have to
make sure that each item is 1/3 of the
container now we can use flexbox and the
syntax is slightly different but if you
look closely I am still trying to make
the Flex basis 1/3 of the container so
that everything lines up in three
columns for the three techniques that I
just Illustrated the grid isn't real
it just looks as if there is a grid
because we forced all the items to line
up with each other but with grid grid is
the only layout technique that
establishes a relationship between the
rows and columns the grid is real so the
way we want to use CSS grid in our
layouts you involves two steps you first
define your grid and then you place
items in it either by yourself or you
can choose to let the browser do it for
you so we'll first talk about some
properties that apply onto the grid
container and this is what defines the
structure and sizing of the different
tracks of your grid
so some people have said some people who
have been reluctant to pick up CSS green
have often mentioned that Oh CSS grid it
seems so complicated there are so many
properties oh I'll just use bootstrap
because bootstrap is the best well I'm
here to tell you that you don't have to
know all the properties to start using
grid in fact you only need to know two
properties to start using grid and they
are bit template columns and grid
template rows so with this with these
two lines you've essentially created a
grid and the code for CSS grid is as
visual as its layout should be because
you can see from the code itself that
you have three columns and you have two
rows and just to make things a little
little interesting we will add a great
gap with just one line of text
essentially these three properties can
get you started with using CSS grid but
of course that is not all that CSS grid
can do so this is one of the suggestions
that I have for everybody here tonight
is that why don't we see control of your
designs to the browsers that are
supposed to render them I mean we've
come from a time where we've always
tried to micromanage every single pixel
on the page we've always tried to make
everything fit exactly the way we want
only to find that our designs are broken
when it's viewed on a different viewport
because nowadays people use the web in
all different kinds of contexts I could
be using a phone which is about 480
pixels wide I could be viewing it on a
if I don't know how much that is 70 inch
television screen so we do not control
how our designs are being build so why
not cede control of the designs to the
browsers that render them so what CSS
green introduces a number of new units
and a number of new functions that allow
us to seek control of the
of your grid to the browser and one of
them is this thing called an fr unit
which represents a fraction of three
space in the grid container so what it
does is that after all the space has
been allocated to the fixed units for
example in in here I'm using 150 the
remaining space will be distributed
according to the ratio that you define
so in this case item B and I am seeing a
sized in a ratio of 1 is to 2 so in a
sense if I'm viewing this particular
piece of code on a phone or on a big
screen I don't actually know how big
item B or C will be I only know that
they will be displayed in the ratio of 1
is to 2 and what we can achieve with
such and the type of a pick we can
achieve is something like this in the
video you can see here I'm actually
asking the browser to give me repeated
patterns of columns in the ratio of 3 to
2 and because I'm using an F our unit
every single column will fill up the
width of the entire viewport because
I've told it to do that now another
function that CSS grid defines is
something called the min Max function
which lets us do something that we've
never been able to do before on the web
and that is to define a range of values
so now I can actually tell the browser
that I want my column to be between the
width of x and y and the browser will
figure out exactly what that width
should be not me so here you can also
use a repeat function because let's say
you're having a grid that is very
complicated maybe it has I don't know 25
columns we're not gonna sit around and
type 25 values into the grid template
columns property we can use the repeat
function which allows us to repeat
patterns of tracks so in this particular
case I'm asking the browser to repeat
the pattern of 75 pixels and 120 pixels
4 times and that's why I have eight
columns and other than explicitly
stating how many times I want a pattern
to repeat I can actually let the browser
do that for me because at the end of the
day the browser is a piece of software
and software can do math better than you
I don't care what you think so rather
than waste precious brain cells on doing
calculations that the browser can do for
you just let the browser do the man come
on guys so what we have is the key words
of autofit and autofit which allow the
browser to determine how many tracks
they need to create depending on the
track size that you have told it so the
only difference between autofill and
autofit is that all of it collapses
empty tracks so we can see how this
actually works so in this example I have
a function that is supposed to repeat
the pattern of 2.5 M columns but if I
have more space than 2.5 m/s the browser
is free to make the columns larger so
now that I'm using autofill I only have
6 bit items and they filled up the six
columns accordingly but there's more
space to the right the browser actually
respects the fact that the space is
there but if I change this value to
autofit it will collapse the empty
columns and fill up the remaining space
instead that's the only difference and
you can use this for a variety of
designs if you so choose so what this
allows us to do is it allows us to
create responsive grids without the need
for media queries because in the past
when I used to work for an agency I'd
have designers give me designs for a
standard grid layout maybe it could be
for products it could be bought for
images you know a standard grid of
images or or you know car cut patterns
are really popular and they will tell me
can you collapse it from 4 columns to 3
columns to 2 to 1 and I know no you
cannot do that because before we had CSS
great we could not do that
without a slew of media queries and
personally I don't like writing a
thousand and one media queries so I just
look at my designer and say hell no I'm
not doing that but now with only two
lines two lines of CSS I literally can
let my design go from five columns to
four columns to three to two to one
without writing a single media query by
using the functions that I mentioned
earlier of min/max of repeat of autofill
and this is a big reason why I think CSS
green has the potential to revolutionize
web design because it makes creating
interesting layouts a lot easier so
another part of building layouts on the
web involves aligning items and aligning
items can be very tricky because the
properties sometimes tend to confuse
people so just don't word of warning you
might get confused with what I'm going
to say in this next section so there are
six properties that you can use to align
stuff in your layout and often people
get mixed up with like what does justify
do what does align do what does content
mean what are atoms so for me personally
the way I remember is that I've been
justifying text in Microsoft Word since
I was this tall right
so if justify is for the direction that
text flows it goes it's logically
speaking the other direction must be
aligned so we've got directions set the
next three values of content self and
items will make sense once you
understand exactly what they do so with
justify or align content what you can do
is you can align all your columns and
rows if there's extra space in the
container so you can use values like
start center or end to sort of
distribute all your rows or columns but
you can also dispute distribute the
space between your grid tracks using
values like space around or maybe space
between so this table will sum up
essentially what you can potentially do
with this but just remember
that content is for shifting entire
blocks within its container
now justify and align itself our self
alignment properties so you use these to
align the content within each grid item
and similarly you use the values of
start center and end and because my
slide is cut off you probably can't see
but I don't see as align to the end the
default value is stretch so if you have
a grid cell by default if you don't do
anything to it the content is just gonna
fill up the entire grid cell justify and
align items simply affects every single
item in your grid so think of it as a
book setting so for anybody who is
confused by all this trust me when I say
that it gets easier with experience so
earlier I mentioned that bidding flexbox
play really well together and this is an
example of that in real life so the
image on the left is a very old-school
design for from the Bauhaus school and
this particular design can be duplicated
on the web and what is striking about
this design is those thick black borders
you see and the way that we can actually
achieve such a design because if you
look closely you'll notice that each
grid cell contains a different type of
content and they're aligned differently
and in order to make sure that
everything is semantic meaning all none
of this is an image other than the
pictures themselves the text is all text
you can highlight the text and in order
to achieve such an effect grid alone is
not sufficient because if you use
yourself alignment properties on each
grid item the moment you try to align
them when you apply a border on the grid
item it will simply take up the width or
height of the content so this kind of
screws on the design this is not what I
want I want my borders to be along my
grid lines so in order to do that we
actually keep each grid item as it is
and apply a display flex to each item
making them a Flex container so it's a
nest
effect and with this nested effect I can
keep my black bodice while still
adjusting the content within each grid
cell remember awesome together now the
next thing we want to talk about is
properties on the grid item which allows
us to position grid items in the grid
think of it like you're placing pieces
on a chessboard
right so you can actually place items
based on the grid lines which have a
numerical index starting from 1 or you
can also actually name your lines and
there's no limit to how many names you
can give your lines and this is useful
because if you have a really complicated
bit you're not gonna spend time counting
which grid line you want to hit you want
to actually name your grid lines in a
way that makes it easy for you to target
them so in this case if I want content
to go into the big main area I could use
their numerical values of 2/3 but I
could also use the named lines of
contents that and content n so what you
can do is you can apply these numerical
values or names to the grid column or
grid row properties so in this example
you can see that everything by default
takes up one grid cell but of course you
don't have to have them you can actually
make them spend multiple grid cells and
you can do things because of this you
can actually do things like overlap so
you can also place items in your grid by
naming the areas that they're supposed
to go so if you look at the code here
you have something called grid template
areas which essentially mirror what you
see in your actual design the code looks
exactly like how it would appear on your
design and this makes it a lot more
visual and easy to understand if you're
writing CSS grid code so when you use
grid areas what you can do is you can
set where you want your good item to be
and just forget about it so if you want
to say you want to work a different
design you don't don't actually have to
go into each individual grid item and
change their sizing
what you can do is that you can directly
just manipulate the grid template areas
to sort of change how you want your
items to be positioned and this I find
is a really convenient solution to a
very common use case so one of the
things that we can achieve with CSS grid
is vertical whitespace which was
something we couldn't do before and
using the grid areas property we can do
that for example here I'm just gonna
skip forward so you can see the end
result the code is such that at each
viewport width I don't actually change
the sizing of Migrante item I merely
change the grid structure at each
viewport and you can also do overlap
like I mentioned before and because
overlap is something that we don't see
often on the web because it's tricky if
you use something like absolute
positioning you have to do a lot of math
to make sure everything fits just right
and you can't guarantee that when you
change the viewport size things will
look the same so grit actually helps in
this regard and when you start building
using grid you'll realize that pencil
and paper is your best friend with that
you can plan your grid beforehand and
you can sort of figure out which column
which tracks need to be flexible which
need to be fixed and so on and so forth
and then you can actually layer on
styles accordingly because
understandably grid is not supported in
every browser so some people are gonna
ask what about the old browsers what
about browsers that don't support bid
well if you don't remember anything
about what I say today please remember
this that websites do not need to look
the same in every browser because the
web is a dynamic medium it is the only
medium that allows you to present a
different design depending on what
context your user is viewing your design
and I think that is the coolest part
about designing for the web because
you actually don't design one static
design you just your design can morph
depending on where you view it on
whether you view it on us on a phone or
whether you view it on a 70 inch
television screen so the end result of
this is something like that that you can
see how the design changes across
different viewport sizes across
different heights and this is totally
possible because of CSS grid something
that we could never do before
so in order to able in order to support
older browsers we'd use something called
feature queries which use the syntax at
supports basically what happens is that
if a browser supports the value inside
the parentheses it will pick up the
properties inside the block but if it
doesn't the entire block is ignored
which makes it really easy to write
fallback styles and support for future
queries is really good even if ie
doesn't support it now you know that I
is going to be deprecated eventually and
it's it's something that you can work
around because every single browser out
there does support feature queries so I
want to wrap up by saying that CSS isn't
a programming language it requires a
different mental model around it so when
you think of CSS think of water think of
how water flows and even though you
cannot directly control the flow of
rushing water you can shape it to your
benefit so when you encounter a CSS
shape it and just engage the flow
embrace the Cascade and see where it
continued thank you very much